hello and welcome to this video playing
that is Manian devil and he goes g6 hmm
yeah let's go see three and lost the
myrrh oxy point last time which was
really bit was very annoying so let's
see what the Tasmanian devil has in
store yeah here you take and kill ninety
two black is some having a hard time to
get c5 and in this pollution see see not
going to take it's almost an automatic
move no we does not take huh yeah night
b3 is most obvious choice one thing is
that this night has no square cm cannot
even go to a5 now
yeah are we going to play that I mean I
can just take it hmm yeah okay
maybe g5g for some an idea for black
not entirely certain how I shall play
this I mean from structure point of view
it's nice but I'm sorry my voice is
really failing me this morning like the
spawn is eternally weak but still blacks
position does not look they're terrible
he might be able to still be okay him
let's put this him
yeah the night is not really good damn
but I'm not sure where to put it
hmm what does it make any sense and icon
before but this is difficult to get in
maybe this more huh hi Scott g5 if they
were silly and maybe g5 isn't so bad for
me
yeah yeah this I expected and I felt
that this should be quite good but hmm
he could have played g5 and then taken
on f3 and now I have f3 on the agenda
that was the idea
okay
really unsure about all this but now a
bishop aged three years getting more of
a thing if I play 93 I mean an f3 is
unprotected
maybe this is a way to play Ruby III
get on the e-file
let's gotta sorta Bishop on g7 and flex
bishop a long-term could could become
strong for sure at the moment they're
not doing terribly much but with my
change I would definitely like to trade
the ships but don't quite see how this
could could happen
sure
maybe I should consider f4 at some point
now maybe I should do that actually
trying to open open the Kings side a
little bit
okay he's taking a bit of time that's
good I mean I was down on the clock but
now he's catching up okay so not no
easier for that same
hmm
what is that possible mind I don't think
it is
hmm there was a very tense position and
any blonde at the house okay so it's all
very very standard age three and now
normally it gets taken mush about five I
mean it should be better for white
anyway but I don't think I managed to
prove it all that convincingly yeah
maybe taking that's not great and Jen
likes roofie one more maybe maybe I mean
here I don't think it looks like much
it's just equal okay that was a stupid
decision I simply forgot or overlooked
whatever you may call it that he can
play G Phi at first I was of course I'm
seeing this which is excellent really
but i only after moving it I saw that g5
Bishop back and then taking as possible
and that is a bit awkward I mean okay
the engine does not state that I'm in
huge trouble but it's really not what I
wanted he played Knight f5 and now I
could get this reading in back and yeah
I don't know this rook maneuver I think
we're just dealing with a somewhat equal
players position here group e8 yeah
now he just has to take and then we play
this I mean again I think it's roughly
equal I don't really have any pressure
on c6 and that is the main potential
reason why white could have anything
that you have some play against the
spawn but yeah it doesn't really
materialize and then you get figure in
the house with King f8 ok guys thanks
for watching